would you rather give up the hungover  breakfast sandwich or the drunk pizza  you want to know what's sad is that i  have ibs and i can't eat bread or cheese  this is really a hypothetical for me i  would give up  the drunk  breakfast sandwich  the hungover breakfast sandwich because  drunk pizza  oh  i almost thought i had done um cocaine  in vegas once because i woke up and  there was like white powdery stuff in my  belly button and i touched it and i  tasted it and i was like oh  parmesan cheese  and i had just eaten so much drunk pizza  that i like dumped a loose quarter cup  of parm down my shirt  and then just slept on it and didn't  know so  i would i would keep the drunk pizza i  love it back the [ __ ] out of the fact  that you were down to ride that morning  oh this day is gonna go one of two  different ways right now